PROFESSOR: Many
mathematical models
involve high order derivatives.
But the MATLAB ODE
solvers only work
with systems of first
order ordinary differential
equations.
So we have to rewrite the
models to just involve
first order derivatives.
Let's see how to do that with a
very simple model, the harmonic
oscillator.
x double prime plus x equals 0.
This involves a second
order derivative.
So to write it as a
first order system,
we introduced the vector y.
This is a vector with
two components, x,
and the derivative of x.
We're just changing
notation to let y
have two components,
x and x prime.
Then the derivative
of y is the vector
with x and x double prime.
So the differential
equation now becomes
y2 prime plus y1 equals zero.
Do you see how we've just
rewritten this differential
equation.
so y2 prime is playing
of x double prime?
Once you've done that,
everything else is easy.
The vector system is now
y1, y2 prime is y2 minus y1.
The first components
says y1 prime is y2.
That's just saying
that the derivative
of the first component
is the second.
Here's the differential
equation itself.
Y2 prime is minus y1 is the
actual harmonic oscillator
differential equation.
When we write this as an
autonomous function for MATLAB,
here's the autonomous function.
f is an autonomous
function of t and y,
that doesn't depend upon t.
First it's a vector
now, a column vector.
The first component of f is y2.
And the second component is -y1.
The first component here is
just a matter of notation.
All the content is in the second
component, which expresses
the differential equation.
Now for some
initial conditions--
suppose the initial conditions
are that x of 0 is 0,
and x prime of 0 is 1.
In terms of the vector
y, that's y1 of 0,
the first component of y is 0.
And the second component is 1.
Or in vector terms, the
initial vector is 0, 1.
That implies they solution
is sine t and cosine t.
When we write the initial
condition in the MATLAB,
it's the column vector 0, 1.
Let's bring up the
MATLAB command window.
Here's the
differential equation.
y1 prime is y2.
And y2 prime is -y1.
Here's the harmonic oscillator.
We're going to
integrate from 0 to 2pi,
because they're trig functions.
And I'm going to ask for output
in steps of 2 pi over 36,
which corresponds
to every 10 degrees
like the runways at an airport.
I'm going to need an
initial condition.
y0 not is 0.
I need a column vector, 0,
1, for the two components.
I'm going to use
ODE45, and if I call it
with no output arguments, ODE45
of the differential equation f,
t span the time interval,
and y0 the initial condition.
If I call ODE45 with
no output arguments,
it just plots the
solution automatically.
And here we get a graph
of cosine t starting at 1,
and sine t starting at 0.
Now if I go back to
the command window,
and ask to capture
the output in t and y,
I then get vectors of output.
37 steps, vector t,
and two components
y, the two columns
containing sine and cosine.
Now I can plot them
in the phase plane.
Plot ya against y2.
If I regularize the axes, I
get a nice plot of a circle
with small circles every
10 degrees, as I said,
like the runways at an airport.
The Van der Pol oscillator
was introduced in 1927
by Dutch electrical engineer, to
model oscillations in a circuit
involving vacuum tubes.
It has a nonlinear damping term.
It's since been used
to model phenomena
in all kinds of
fields, including
geology and neurology.
It exhibits chaotic behavior.
We're interested in it
for numerical analysis
because, as the
parameter mu increases,
the problem becomes
increasingly stiff.
To write it as a first
order system for use
with the MATLAB ODE solvers,
we introduce the vector y,
containing x and x prime.
So y prime is x prime
and x double prime.
And then the
differential equation
is written so that the first
component of y prime is y2.
And then the
differential equation
is written in the
second component of y.
Here's the nonlinear
damping term minus y1.
When mu is 0, this becomes
the harmonic oscillator.
And here it is as the
anonymous function.
Let's run some experiments with
the Van der Pol oscillator.
First of all, I have to
define the value of mu.
And I'll pick a
modest value of mu.
Mu equals 100.
And now with mu set, I can
define the anonymous function.
It involves a value of mu.
And here is the Van
der Pol equation
in the second component of f.
I'm going to gather statistics
about how hard the ODE
solver works.
And for that, I'm
going to use ODE set,
and tell it I want
to turn on stats.
I need an initial condition.
Now I'm going to run
ODE45 on this problem.
And I'm specifying just
a starting value of t,
and a final value of t.
ODE45 is going to pick
its own time steps.
And I know with t
final equals 460,
it's going to integrate
over it about two
periods of the solution.
Now we can watch
it go for a while.
It's taking lots of steps.
And it's beginning
to slow down as it
takes more and more steps.
Now this begins to get painfully
slow as it runs into stiffness.
I'll turn off the
camera for a while here,
so you don't have to
watch all these steps.
We're trying to
get up here to 460.
And I'll turn it back on
as we get close to the end.
OK, well, the camera's been
off about three minutes.
And you can see how
far we've gotten.
We're nowhere near the end.
So I'm going to press
the stop button here.
And we'll go back to
the command window.
And oh, so we didn't
get to the end here.
Let me back off on
the time interval
and try this value here.
See how that works.
So this is going to
still take lots of steps.
But we'll be able to-- This
will go over about one period.
We'll actually get
to the end here.
I'll leave the camera
on until we finish.
OK so that took a
little under a minute.
And it took nearly 15,000 steps.
So let's run it
with a stiff solver.
There.
So it took half a second,
and only 500 steps.
So there's a modest
example of stiffness here.
So let's examine the
Van der Pol equation
using the stiff solver.
Let's capture the
output and plot it.
Because that plot
wasn't very interesting.
I want to plot it a
couple of different ways.
And again, I want to go
back up to the-- capture
a couple periods.
Let's plot one of the
current components
as a function of time.
And here it is.
Here's the Van der Pol equation.
And you can see it has
an initial transient,
and then it settles into
this periodic oscillation
with these really
steep spikes here.
And even this stiff
solver is working hard
at these rapid changes.
We've got a fair
number of points
in here, as it is it
chooses the step size.
And now, let's go back
to the command line
and do a phase plane plot.
So here's the phase plane
plot of this oscillator
with damping.
And it's nowhere near a circle,
which it would be if mu was 0.
And this is the characteristic
behavior of the Van der Pol
oscillator.